could you think of a better introduction
into the mcu than being part of this
family
no
quite simply absolutely not i think that
re-re-entering into this universe this
beautiful universe is
it's an opportunity for a lot of people
to feel i think seen
and i think that having that couched in
this movie that is so or the story that
is so rich in this world that is so
vibrant and that everybody loves so much
for such intimate and warm reasons i
think is probably one of the best ways
that riri could have our entrance
people are already having huge emotional
reactions to the trailer i think i'm
still shaking a little bit inside from
watching it please talk to me about how
the world has expanded um we've got the
atlanteans in there and yeah obviously
you're not going to give away what's
going on between them but how you guys
have grown together in presenting this
new version of the world to everybody
how we've grown together in presenting
this new one
sounds like he's looking for a
spoiler i don't know how to answer that
you're going to have to ask another
question
i mean that's what we're doing you know
what i'm saying
some people are too tricky some people
the comic-con audience has been waiting
and they are they've been waiting and
ready for this can you talk about what
it felt like being out there to finally
present
this to all of them
yeah i mean it was um it was very
emotional there was a lot of emotions
that we had going in like you know
the loss of our of our leader and our
king
um
and and hearing ryan talk about him in
the beginning for us backstage was very
very it really was you know it was it
hit and it was very it was very
confusing in a sense to walk on there
without him you know and um and at the
same time
there was there was a gratitude and a
thank and a pride in what
i think what we've done and i think what
we've done
you know i dare say
honors him so it was all those feelings
it was all those things and really the
the joy and the love from from hall h is
is just is an indescribable thing
it it really is invigorating and and
and uplifting really um and i've i've
been fortunate to experience a lot of
quality she's going to experience a lot
of holidays
and
there's nothing like it
so i'm just very thankful for for the
experience always
i love that thank you so much
thanks appreciate you guys